تتعقب المعدات الموجودة في هذه الغرفة كل
حركة تقوم بها والشركة الناشئة التي تستخدمها
وتقول إنها تكلف أكثر من مليون
دولار ، فما يحدث عندما تحاول
تقليص هذه التقنية إلى جهاز ميسور التكلفة
يشبه زوجًا من السراويل القصيرة
لجهاز الكمبيوتر والأخطبوط  لقد قطع طفل
ديميترا شوطًا طويلاً منذ
النموذج الأولي الأول ، وهو يحاول اليوم
إنشاء بعض من أكثر التقنيات الذكية التي يمكن ارتداؤها
في السوق ، غالبًا ما
تمارس مالينا في الهواء الطلق في هذه الجامعة اليونانية ،
لكن سروالها الضيق
يجمع البيانات كما لو كانت تعمل
هنا كمحترف  - مختبر للميكانيكا الحيوية من الدرجة
التي يمكن أن يقيس ويحلل
عمليًا كل حركة عضلية في
الوقت الفعلي مثل هذا المرشد
العادي الآخر الأشخاص العاديين
المخصصين للجامعات أو سومانث أو
الرياضيين بملايين اليورو والمشكلة أنه
لا يمكنك الحصول على واحدة إلا إذا كنت  سباق خارق
لكن ديميتري يأمل في حل هذه
المشكلة مع شركته للملابس الذكية
Tribe التي تلبس الشركة الناشئة التي تصنع
الملابس الرياضية التي يزيد
قياسها عن مائة  المتغيرات من إجهاد العضلات إلى معدل
ضربات القلب إلى التنسيق ،
كان في عام 2013 أن شارك ديميترا فكرته لأول مرة
مع أستاذ الميكانيكا الحيوية
الذي يعمل الآن في تجربته ، كانت أول
كلمة مفادها أن هذا الجنون
حقًا هو ما يفعله هذا الجنون بشأن نيكو ، حيث
أن الشكوك قائمة على أسس سليمة
التكنولوجيا القابلة للارتداء التي يعرفها معظم المستهلكين
كانت ولا تزال تهيمن عليها
الساعات الذكية وأجهزة تتبع اللياقة البدنية التي
تجمع فقط الأساسيات التي
تحاول القبيلة اتباعها مع هذه المنتجات
بملابس تجمع بيانات أكثر تفصيلاً
ومحددة باستخدام ما لا يقل عن عشرة
أجهزة استشعار لكل آلة قابلة للتمدد
توفر المنتجات القابلة للغسل
ملاحظات حية على جهاز ذكي
بهدف مساعدة الهواة على إنشاء مزيد من
التدريبات المخصصة ومساعدة الرياضيين
وتركيز تدريبهم لك
ولأني أرى حقًا
المعلومات الدقيقة التي تقترب من
أن يراها العالم لا تصنعها
منطقيًا لذلك نجعل المعلومات
سهلة الفهم قدر الإمكان ، يقول الفريق
إنهم يعملون  مع نصف دزينة من
الشركات بما في ذلك شركة صينية لتصنيع الملابس الرجالية
وشركة فرنسية ناشئة
، وهم يأملون أن تبدأ منتجاتهم الأولى
في البيع في منتصف عام 2020 ،
وقد تم الترويج لملابس Mart على أنها
التقنية الكبيرة التالية القابلة للارتداء لسنوات ولكن
مقارنة بأكبر قطاعين
في الصناعة  من المتوقع أن تمثل الساعات الذكية وأجهزة
تعقب اللياقة البدنية مثل هذه
6 ٪ فقط من السوق بحلول عام
2023 وفقًا لأبحاث جونيبر ، لكن
ديميترا لا تدع الاحتمالات تردعه
لأن سعيه شخصيًا ، حيث
منعته إصابة في الركبة في الكلية من
لعب كرة السلة و  إن إحباطه
أثناء عملية التعافي هو ما
دفعني إلى هذه الرحلة ، لقد فات
الأوان لفعل أي شيء لهذا الجزء ،
ولم يفت الأوان لمنع حدوث شيء
لشخص آخر